BRIAN SUK: Hey, Lorin.
LORIN PRICE: Hey, Brian.
BRIAN SUK: Did you know
that my sister's husband's
mother's uncle was married
to your great grandmother?
LORIN PRICE: Wait.
How did you figure that out?
Does that mean we're related?
BRIAN SUK: Well, I
loaded our family trees
onto JanusGraph running
on Google Cloud Bigtable,
ran some queries, and found out.
No, I'm just kidding
with you, but I
can tell you some pretty
interesting things
about the Greek gods.
LORIN PRICE: Let's check it out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIAN SUK: JanusGraph
is an open source,
distributed graph database.
Amongst its many
different features,
one of the key
strengths of JanusGraph
is the idea of
pluggable storage.
You can use various
storage back end
technology such as
Apache's Cassandra, HBase,
or in our case, we're going
to use Google Cloud Bigtable.
So let's go ahead and
create Bigtable cluster.
We're going to call
this JanusGraph.
And as you can see
here, there are
a number of different options
that you can configure.
Let's set up a
production instance
to show what this looks like.
We're going to choose
solid-state disk
since we are just testing this
and wants to run it quickly.
We're also going to
deploy this in US central1
in the F zone, set it for
the minimum production
size of three nodes for a
cluster, and away we go.
Now that our
cluster is deployed,
we're going to use our Cloud
Shell to deploy JanusGraph
itself, which we're going to
deploy onto a Google Kubernetes
Engine cluster that we have also
created in advance for this.
We will use Helm to set this up.
While this is deploying, let's
take a look at the sample graph
that we're going to use
for the demonstration
and see what that looks like.
Here is the sample graph
data that we will be
using for this demonstration.
The sample data set is both
in the Google Cloud tutorial
and is also available on
the JanusGraph tutorial.
The graph of the gods
outlines the relationships
between various
ancient Greek gods,
their pets, the monsters
they battled, and also
where they lived.
Different entities that you
see here with attributes
are referred to as vertexes,
and the relationships
between those vertexes
are called edges.
So for example, in the lower
left side of this graph,
we can see that, at the start
of the vertex labeled Hercules,
there is an edge
protruding from that
on the right that shows that
he has battled a monster named
Cerberus.
What this enables us to do
is query the relationships
between different entities.
When storing this
kind of information
in a regular
relational database,
it typically requires
complex joints
to manage, especially so
when the level of joining
gets multiple layers deep.
With graph traversal
languages, this
makes it far more intuitive
and easier to query
these different relationships.
This also requires a new
language to query it,
and in JanusGraph, we call
this language Gremlin.
To start off with, let's
just run a simple command
to find the name of
Jupiter's brother.
In a relational database,
you would perform a query
across two tables.
Here, we see that this
command is starting
from a vertex, denoted g.V,
that has the name Jupiter,
and we are looking for outward
relationships of type brother
and want the values
of those names.
Neptune and Pluto
is what comes back,
which matches with what's
on the graph on the right.
Now let's look at
the edges themselves.
Instead of just looking
up where Pluto lives,
we now want to see why, which
is an attribute of an edge.
So the query here
also starts at Pluto,
but now we're looking
for an outward edge
denoting where he lives, and
we want to look at the reason.
In a typical
relational database,
this would always involve some
sort of gods table, a location
table, and most likely some
form of a cross-reference table
between the two.
You can start to see how graph
traversal makes these kinds
of operations far easier.
Lastly, let's look at a
query with yet another join.
Here, we want to see a
third level relationship
from Jupiter.
In this case, we
want to see where
Jupiter's brother's dog lives.
If we see here, the query
simply just starts at Jupiter,
looks for the next level
relationship marked brother,
then looks for his pet, and
finally returns where he lives.
If we see the result
here, it's marked
as Tartarus, which
corresponds also
to the visual representation
of the graph on the right.
So there you have a few quick
examples of graph traversal.
And what's really cool about
this particular architecture
is that, because it is
backed by Google Cloud
Bigtable as a
storage mechanism, we
know that this
architecture will allow
this to scale as large as
the graph is going to grow.
So now you've seen that by
using JanusGraph on Google Cloud
Platform, you can make some
pretty useful connections
in the data that you
wouldn't normally
be able to make in a
transactional SQL database.
And also, if you want to run
this tutorial for yourself,
be sure to check
out the link below.
LORIN PRICE: If you
enjoyed this video,
don't forget to like,
comment, and subscribe
for more great Google
Cloud Platform content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]